For coming tonight.
[inaudible] you
need to read this.
The second city,
I just came back from London.
I talked to Sam parents.
That's Murray,
so I was very interesting and hopefully those videos in August,
that's the plan.
Once they're all properly edited,
if for some point in all of that,
they're not going to be edited for content just for quality.
That's the plan.
Anyways,
it's very nice to see all of you here to partake in what I hope will be,
what will be a serious of useful and meaningful.
I want him to talk to you tonight.
I told her I'd take you through 12 rules for life through the lens of courage.
It's a nice virtue to contemplate a good entry point into the content of the
book.
Can I use these lectures as an opportunity to take past what I've already
written to try to make it more coherent and to try to push my thinking in new
directions and so that it stays fresh and vital and so that I learned something
because you can learn something by thinking,
which is generally why people do it.
So I wanted to tell you some things.
First of all about stealing.
Um,
theories and instinct.
We have a separate neural for theater.
It's the circuit that's affected by drugs that you might take like alcohol,
because alcohol is a very powerful and to anxiety.
Anxiety and fear are very similar.
Technically,
people think of ancient anxiety as a fear of something that some nonspecific,
you know,
you'd like to feel anxiety about going to a park or a new job or something like
that.
Word might have a phobia,
might be afraid of spiders or snakes or for myself or,
or some port Allen elevators or being exposed to the outside world that Viagra
phobia.
So fear is usually if something specific and anxiety is that something more
general.
But in any case,
we haven't fear circuit,
it's very old.
It's designed to stop us from being damaged.
So essentially you become afraid of things that might damage it might hurt
review.
We can reframe.
You become afraid of things that might punish and you have a separate circuit
for pain too,
which is a response to punishment.
So pain is usually a signal that something's about to damage.
Some that or something is damaging that's more accurate and pain is a pain.
Pain can be staved off opiates,
right.
Those are technically analgesics.
It's fear and anxiety.
It can be staved off by NGS.
I'll let it's technically speaking.
Those include the alcohol had been such as paints like Valium,
Xanax and so forth and instruments which are not very commonly used it more
medically or for nonmedical state recreational purposes,
but alcohol is a drug that people really liked because it dampens fear and
anxiety,
which is what people,
it's one of the many reasons that people use alcohol,
social circumstances.
Alcohol is a variety of neurochemical effects that vary substantially depending
on who it is constricting because people are differentially sensitive to that
neurochemical effects of alcohol.
Some people,
especially people with social anxiety who are sensitive to the anxiety,
letting properties like to drink if they are in a social circumstance because it
makes them less afraid and I sang as you're seeing other people also get out of
stimulant kicked.
Got It.
Alcohol,
if you're one of those people that has a hard time stopping when you start
drinking and you'd probably get a stimulant and kicking from alcohol,
that's dangerous.
That's one of the things that can be used and predispose you to alcoholism.
So if you have that response anywhere,
but it also means it,
you really enjoy a level.
So it's harder to be careful that those circumstances because it's such a
wonderful drug,
if that's,
if that's the situation that you're in.
Do you have a separate fear circuit?
And the point of fear and anxiety is to stop you when you see things that might
damage pain signals that you are being damaged,
series signifies that you might be damaged.
And so it's a newer circuit from an evolutionary perspective.
Then the pain,
because it takes a smarter animal.
It's one thing to get the hell out of there when you're in pain,
but it's another thing to be wary when you might be in pain.
That's what fear is for.
And so it's a very unpleasant emotion,
of course,
although perhaps not as bad as pain.
Um,
and I guess that's the,
that's the logical substitute isn't,
it's not so bad and emotion compared to pain you need here to protect you
because you can be heard.
So there's plenty of things to be afraid of,
an anxious about in the world because not only can you be hurt,
you know that you can be heard.
That's one of the things that really distinguishes human beings from other
creatures.
We have a very,
very clear apprehension of our borders and limitations.
We know that even if there's nothing that's making us anxious right here and
right now,
we know that there are things that might come our way that are quite negative in
the future.
And so to some degree,
part of the reason that you would beats are always so conscious of hyper
consciousness because we weld them safe as we aren't right now.
Something is still lurking around the corner that might,
that might do a CMP.
If you watch animals like zebras hold on the African film,
they're pretty strange in some ways that their cognitive resources in their
emotional responses are quite limited.
You know,
Zebra heard can be surrounded by lions and as long as the lions aren't getting a
hunting configuration is he was don't really seem to mind the alliance,
which seems a little bit shortsighted on their part if the Zealand don't seem to
be able to figure out what those sweeping lions are.
Also the same lines that are going to need them tomorrow.
But I guess maybe the advantage of being a zebra and not caring about the
sleeping minds is that while you don't have to be nervous,
except when you're being hunted to where as human beings in a situation like
that would be thinking those damn lions,
they look like they're sleeping.
But you know what,
they'll be up to tomorrow.
And of course we do know what things will be up to tomorrow and that means we
can protect ourselves and it's what's coming tomorrow.
But it's at the cost of eternal vigilance.
And so that's part of the reason why we're susceptible to drugs like and spasm
beats and barbecue.
It's an alcohol because those drugs to help us quell our internal anxiety.
And so now with when psychologists for starting to study fear,
they thought about it wrong.
Um,
but I'm going to go through the way they thought about it because sometimes if
you think about something wrong,
you think about it wrong in an interesting way.
And if you think about something in detail wrong,
at least then you can learn exactly why you're wrong and maybe you could figure
out how not to be wrong with you.
Keep thinking,
which is part of the reason by the way,
that free speech is so important because in order to get to the truth,
you have to do a lot of wandering through error.
And so you have to be allowed and even encouraged to be stumbling realm and
stupid,
careless and objectionable,
offensive and all of those things in your speech.
Because if you can't come around stupidly,
you're never going to be able to think anything through because you have to know
how to speak properly to begin with about something complex.
If you're going to do it properly and you don't know how to do complicated
things that you don't understand property and so you're not going to speak about
this very well and so it'd be good to speak about them at all,
which you have to want to learn about them.
Then you have to be encouraged to stumble around badly.
I have this program and that some of you might be interested.
It's part of the self authoring suite,
which is a sequence of writing programs that my colleagues and I generated to
help people clinically.
I would say we were trying to figure out how we could bring clinically powerful
technologies to a mass market at a very low cost.
We discovered through reading the relevant literature and through our own
scientific research that if you had people write about uncertainty,
then that would make them more productive and more engaged,
healthier.
Many people have done research of that sort.
No,
not off put by it.
It needs to be definitely in my class.
The first program was passed off free program and it helps people write and
structured autobiography.
So it helps you divide your life up into six parts and then great about the
emotionally significant events in each of those epoxy or s section.
There's a hint in,
this is some three to think about.
It's very relevant to the topic of tonight's talk.
If you have a memory that's older than about 18 months and there's a reason for
that by the way,
but what we'll say 18 months from now and when you bring that memory to mind,
it's still causes an emotional reaction and I'm thinking mostly about a negative
emotion reaction.
That means that you haven't fully processed that memory and it's still weighing
down on you.
And I mean one of the things your brain is always trying to do is try to
calculate how dangerous the current environment is.
And the answer that is something like,
uh,
your brain assumes the current environment is dangerous in proportion to the
number of things that have occurred in your life and you haven't been able to
figure out.
So the more things that you haven't figured out,
the more dangerous you're very,
this is the environment is and the price you paid for that.
If you're more anxious and not only that,
you produce more stress hormones,
especially cortisol.
And the problem with producing excess cortisol,
you need to produce some,
it helps wake you up in the morning.
But if you produce excess excess portal that makes you cool.
And so it contributes to virtually every degenerative physiological process that
we know of.
And so cleaning up your past is actually a really good idea.
You know,
if something that happened in a long time,
it goes to a baud assume.
The reason for that is,
is that the emotional systems,
the underlying emotional systems that helping process the world,
especially the emotions that are associated with fear and anxiety are telling
you that you have encountered something in your pathway in,
in your,
in your past,
in your past that you did on master,
and it still would present a danger to you if you encountered begin.
And so it's,
it's interesting to contemplate that because we don't often think about the
purpose of memory.
We think,
well,
the purpose of memories to remember the past,
that's actually not true.
The purpose of memory is to extract the information hope from the past so you
don't do the same damn stupid thing than once.
And then that truly is the purpose of memory.
That is how your,
that's how your memories are constructed.
That's how your mind looks at the past.
What you're trying to do is to map out the world and you use your past
experience to elaborate up that map and then you use that map to orient yourself
into the future.
Right?
So that's the derivation of wisdom from the past.
And so,
you know,
once you mastered fire,
you don't have to be burned,
right?
You could encounter and truly dangerous things and you can learn how to master
them and then when you would come to them in the future,
they're not dangerous.
And so that's perfect.
Like if you have something in your past can still bought,
I just used.
That means that as far as your underlying emotional systems are concerned,
you are not master of that event.
And that bothers some emotion will never go away until you go back to that
memory and you've figured out how it was that you rendered vulnerable in that
situation and what you would have to do now in order to reconfigure the way you
look at the world or the way that you act so that that vulnerability with
disappeared.
And so if you do the past offering programming reasonably carefully,
um,
reasonably thoroughly,
let's say,
um,
then you can,
you can find all those things in your past.
If you haven't mastered your over common,
that can,
that will update you and it'll make your map more differentiated.
It will make you more skillful and drop your stress levels.
It's also a useful thing to do from a conceptual perspective because as I said
already,
partly what you're trying to do in your life is mapped your way forward,
right?
Because people are forward moving creatures who are always going from point a to
point B.
We're,
we're on a journey or an adventure.
And,
and,
and you need to map out your journey or your invention.
What do you need to know where you're going,
obviously,
but you also have to know where you are.
You know,
if you're using a map,
like an actual announcement,
it's completely useless to just know where you're going.
You also have to know where the hell you are and if you're scattered all over
the place,
which is which,
which is really the case.
If there's a lot of things in your past that are unresolved that it's
extraordinarily hard to map your way forward because you don't even know where
to start.
And so that's,
that's a useful action socks.
And I often encourage people to do that,
exercise that and that
reflects,
that's a reflection of what I first said.
It bubbles on speech.
Thank you.
You have to stumble around and won if you're going to get to where you're going.
And so if you want to write about your past and bring yourself up to date,
you don't have to do it perfectly,
but you definitely have to do it.
You have to confront those things in your past are weighing you down and making
you better and making you're resentful and freezing you in place.
And all of that.
And it's also the case.
We'll get to this in more detail as we progress that.
Um,
you,
you
a minute.
So the second,
the second part of the,
of the self authoring suite helps you identify your virtues and your calls front
of layer stating virtue for thinking.
We talked about faults in the modern world,
but we don't often talk about virtue to,
it's kind of an old fashioned term,
but I picked it specifically for that reason because Virtusa useful terms
virtually isn't,
it's an unbelievably useful term.
In fact,
it's fundamentally a term
rather than a moral term because your virtues are precisely that kit of tools
that's that you have in hand and help you contend the world.
It's best to think of virtues as tools rather than characteristics.
And so if you've been identifying faults,
those are the things that are obstacles to your progress.
And so by your own definition,
but say that's how the exercise is set up and used a pseudonym you want and need
something,
you're pursuing it.
There's going to be elements of their own character that get in the way.
You probably want to do something about that,
assuming that you want to get to where you're going.
And of course you do because if you didn't want to get into areas you wouldn't
the positive as a destination to begin with.
So obviously they want to get there and if you are,
if you do want to get there and there are things about the way you're behaving
in the world that are in the way and obviously it would be better for you to
rectify them.
So that's fair himself rather than,
and then equally it's equally the case that some of characteristics that you
have that will move you forward into the world are going to be useful and you
should know how to capitalize on them and you should be conscious of that
because why not be conscious of it.
It's useful to know yourself so that you can use yourself more effectively.
And then the final exercise is the future authoring program.
We've had lots of fun with that.
I designed that years ago when I noticed in my class this class online maps,
it's classical maps of meaning,
which is the vote by well which just came up in the audio version.
By the way,
do you like 12 rules you might like,
absolutely.
It's a lot harder.
Um,
but it's also about papers.
So if you want to go paper,
well that's going to be harder,
often sleep.
But you know,
if,
if you found from 12 rules for life useful than going deeper might even be more
useful.
And so the audio version might be good for that.
Um,
when I,
that's uh,
it's a book about the story of your life because your life is a story.
A story is a description of how you move from point a to B and what sort of
pitfalls you might encounter along the way.
How you fall apart in your journey towards a higher good and how you put
yourself back together.
That's a story.
Maps of meaning is about what stories are and what perhaps with the greatest
story is,
which is a good thing to know since you have to act out as four minus galacto
great one since what?
Since you don't have better
words,
they think about,
so because the maps of meaning with about stories and because I believe that
people's lives are misconstrued as stories and perhaps even the reality itself
as best construed as a story as otherwise we wouldn't use stories to represented
so continually.
Um,
I had people write up,
start to write up the story of their,
their future life.
So it's kind of an interesting exercise.
Um,
it's,
it's related to rule 10 and 12 for life,
which is beat precisely.
You've speak,
no one's ever told me,
no one's ever really told why you should be precise in your speech.
But the reason is for the same reason that when you shoot a rifle at a target,
you aim at the center,
right?
It's not random.
You don't just sort of pointing your gun and shoot approximately in the
direction of the target.
You specify it as precisely as you can.
And then you pull the trigger.
You might think,
well,
it's a strange thing to use of say a military analogy and analogy with weapons,
but it's not a strange thing at all because if you think about the things that
people do,
if you think about the dramatic things that people do
where people are trying to hit the center of targets all the time and we love
them to see people do that.
We knew that with hockey,
we do that with soccer,
baseball,
basketball,
like the idea of specifying a target and the hitting the center of it or
something that we're absolutely obsessed about that we're so obsessed that
together together new stadiums and watch people do it.
It's only for reading,
contemplating what we're doing.
Do you see as a sports team,
it's a,
it's a cooperative and competitive attachment to specify and hit a target and
we're so excited about that probably because at least in part,
we're built physiologically on a hunting platform and then throwing platform,
right?
I mean human beings can throat and we can throw a punch or throw a ball and
throw a spear.
And that's a big deal.
That's a big part of what we are.
So we're target seeking creatures.
And so it'd be precise in your speeches to specify the target with the
specified.
The target is to have an aim and to have an aim is to have a purpose and to aid
property institute attain your purpose,
at least in principle.
And so partly what we're doing in the future,
authoring Hams and sizes to specify your purpose with your precise speech.
And so we asked people to,
well here's another thing to contemplate.
We are Amy creatures.
We're built on hunting platform.
We'd like to hit targets as possible that we're good at it.
And then what that also means is that well,
if we aren't good at it and that's part of what we are,
then if you specify a target and you might be headed,
and that's a hell of a thing.
There's a,
there's a statement in the New Testament,
it's quite a strange statement and it's a,
it's a,
it's a suggestion in the suggestion is that if you knock,
the door will open and if you ask,
you will receive a new thing.
Well that seems highly unlikely and well it does seem highly unlikely,
right?
Being sure that's the way the world is set up.
It's like,
you know,
that is our school,
the way the world is set up,
it's a very strange thing and it's,
it's not that surprising if you started thinking it through.
And so that mean after all,
prophetically through adapting to the moral evolution has been working three and
a half billion years to produce you.
And so,
you know,
they could've done a better job,
but that's not such a bad job.
And so maybe she could attain your aim.
One of the things I've certainly learned as a clinical psychologist once that a
lot of the people that I saw who were unhappy with their lives say new forties
and sometimes you're be within that and who had him detained what they wanted
haven't attained in often in large part because the never specified and the
probability that you're going to hit a tiny target precisely without aiming at
it is zero.
That's not gonna happen so well.
So what would happen if you would aim at it?
That's a question and how it should be fast aim.
That's another question.
And that's part of what,
12 rules for lights and it's about,
the second rule for example,
is a treat yourself like you're someone responsible for helping.
It's kind of a nice start.
So I could imagine edge and that again is you're aiming a rifle.
You have to put yourself in a certain physiological state,
right?
What I'm,
take some deep breaths and calm down and you want to make sure your hands are
shaking and jiggling and so forth.
You know,
put yourself in the right frame of mind.
And if you're going to take eight with your life,
it's the same thing.
You have to put yourself in the right frame of mind and what's the right frame
of mind.
And it might be something like,
while you can assume that you're actually hypothetically a valuable creature,
even though you might not think that self is,
you're absolutely knowing what the bull about your own flaws and insufficiencies
but independent of value,
you might think,
well you can lend your sofa hand and you can do something good for yourself just
up with the goodness of your heart.
You know,
like you might do for someone that you cared about.
Now that that's actually very difficult for people.
You know,
like most of us love someone or a couple of people,
but just half heartedly at least observe children.
Well,
you know,
it's hard to be fully committed to something.
But in generally way,
generally we do a pretty good job with our,
with our partners or husbands and wives and a pretty good job with her children.
Oh,
it's a little more iffy there.
A decent job,
parents,
well,
you know it's 70 30 or whatever,
but maybe you could make,
you can elevate elevated more than that with a lot of aspirin,
but I don't know how good we are about doing that for ourselves.
I would say much less so.
And part of that is definitely the fact that we're very aware of our own flaws
and insufficiencies personally you know more about how Regine useless.
You are fundamentally then about anyone else.
And so that's rather disheartening given that it's disheartening then it's not
so easy to take care of yourself properly,
but it doesn't go up his to be that you really have to have that right not to
take care of yourself.
I think you have a responsibility to take care of yourself as if something
value which you are.
And so that's a responsibility.
And so when you fill out a future authoring program here,
you're asked to adopt for the sake of experimentation,
the frame of reference,
a frame of reference within which you give yourself the benefit of the doubt and
assume that there's something about you that might be usefully be brought
forward into the world.
And you know,
it's,
it's uh,
an axiom of our society that there is something about you that would be usefully
be brought forward into the world because our whole society is predicated on the
notion of the sovereign individual there even enough and the divided and we
wouldn't have,
uh,
exceeded political power each and every one of us if,
and that would work unless there was actually something to the proposition that
each individual is in fact something approximating and divide locus of value
despite our insufficiencies.
And so allowing yourself the benefit of the doubt seems like and philosophically
appropriate thing and it takes a certain month love and it takes a certain
amount of courage.
And so we ask people to think,
okay,
well here,
here's a game.
You can have it if you ain't mad
possibility.
If you aim it a proper,
and would that make sense?
Because if you ain't been something in property,
you're not going to hit it.
So you could have it and you can hit when you a map.
If you a property.
The question would be how when you,
a proper answer might be,
well imagine you just started to take care of yourself like he was something.
We're thinking carer.
So then you could say,
well,
if you could have what you wanted three to five years down the room,
what would it be?
One of the needed,
assuming you were taking care of yourself.
Like if you,
if you can think about it like you,
I take care of the child.
If you're going to take care of a child,
he wouldn't just grant him or her,
his or her every win.
That's not care.
So that isn't how you can treat yourself.
You have to be more sensible.
How we can say,
well,
okay,
you mean you get to have what you need three to five years down the road?
What do you want from your family?
If you could put your family together the way you wanted it to be together.
So you had,
what do you want it from your father and your mother and your siblings and your
kids,
just hypothetically,
what would that look like?
It probably wouldn't look like the situation where you're all around the
Thanksgiving dinner with your hands around each other's necks,
squeezing slowly,
which is the condition many families are in that Thanksgiving dinner.
You probably wouldn't wish for that and it would probably not be for the basket.
Then you might ask,
well,
what would you want from your,
from your intimate partner,
if you could have what you needed,
what would you want from your career?
And how would you educate yourself if you could do,
we did an auditable way or at least better trends you're managing now.
How would you take care of your mental and physical health?
What would you do outside of work that would be meaningful and engaging in
productive?
Um,
what do you want from your friends?
That's,
that's cool.
Three and 12 for like make friends with the people who want the best for him.
I'd say help.
I think to do that'd be useful.
You know,
cause it's not that easy to do what's best even though it's batched to do what's
best by definition.
It could be useful perhaps to be surrounded by people who are happy when
something good happens to you,
genuinely plates because they know that life is bigger than short and tragic and
then the probability that good things will happen to people is somewhat low.
And then as a consequence of when they do,
it's something to celebrate and who had also perhaps be not so happy if
something bad happened around you and wouldn't necessarily entice you into such
situations.
So that would be a good thing to consider with regards to your friends.
So there's seven things that you think about how to put your life in the kind of
order that would make you actually want to have your rights to not be bitter
about different
and degenerate because of that bitterness.
And then we asked people to write for 15 minutes sale and you get to have one,
which is your life to look like.
And so that would be life.
That fine maximally except let's say,
but realistically,
and so then you have some name out there.
We had to Ms. Hampton,
we've worked on the program for awhile and we had people write for 15 minutes
count provision,
which was okay.
That's where you're headed and you're aiming for,
you're aiming at him kind of fleshing out.
Here's another useful thing you think about.
So you have that habits and you're resentful book things and you don't try as
hard as it might in some dimensions of your weaknesses that might take you a
partner.
Pretty much everybody knows what those weaknesses are.
You know,
some people would smoke too much pot and some people would drink too much and
some people would be unfaithful.
Half counterproductive isn't it?
Some people would end up on the street because they would teach,
generate with regards to the discipline,
everybody kind of knows how they fall apart if they felt apart in their own
idiosyncratic and spectacular manner.
It was the sorts of things that keep you awake at night.
If you,
if you contemplate them deeply,
um,
where would you be in three to five years?
If you let everything go directly to hell,
that's useful.
That's useful because then see,
it's one thing to motivate yourself because you see that what you're doing is
moving you ahead to something that you want,
but that's hope and hope is a powerful
terror.
That's
one of the things I have to deal with.
One clinical sciences there.
Maybe they don't have a job.
They really like,
you know,
and it's grinding away at your soul and it's not,
I can just leap out of your job into another job.
That's actually really complicated problem,
right?
If you don't like your job,
it's not just a psychological problem.
You have to have a job,
otherwise you died.
And so it's
changing.
Jobs is the bathroom and just adjusting itself.
Psychologically,
you might have to do a lot of planning to change your job.
You have to update your CV if you have to update your skills and maybe we've got
to figure out how to be a little bit more credible in an interview and you have
to overcome your fear of rejection.
Like there may be all sorts of things.
African,
we actually save yourself up to move laterally or up to let's say to a different
position when it's more engaging and uh,
you know,
you might be,
you might be looking to do that.
MMM.
And so you're afraid of getting down
and you think,
well,
if I'm afraid of it,
why should I do it?
People ask themselves the same question when they have a difficult conversation
to have with their wives or their children or their parents.
You know,
cause a lot of us are very conflict diverse.
There are difficult conversations to happen public.
And the reason is is because they're awkward.
Did and make us afraid.
So you might think,
well,
why the hell bothered if it makes you afraid?
Why not just not do it?
Which is one of the ideas that keeps people in jobs they hate and in
relationships and stopped him from repairing their relationships with you.
It's a very difficult thing to do and that's what it is.
Well,
let's imagine that you could just keep doing the thing that you don't like them.
You don't change it because you're afraid to,
well,
are you afraid of what happens if you don't change it?
And if you lay out this little hell,
but I described really in one way so you know where you in degenerating if you
were going to degenerate and then you look at your life and can take,
well here's a bunch of things I'm not doing because I'm afraid not s you know,
keeping me secure.
It's like,
no,
it's not.
It's just taking you to that place that you lay down.
It's an absolute catastrophe.
And so sometimes the answer to why should I do this thing that I'd been putting
off is well otherwise they end up in this particular hell.
I already know.
I already know the parameters of it.
And so hope can help you move out of that.
It would be better if I did this,
but fear of not doing it and the consequences as we've been and what's better
yet is to have both of the working in tandem.
So psychologists figured this out when they were looking at theory years ago
because I'm trying to figure out how to motivate our members
to do things like run down a nice update,
a reward.
Turns out that a hungry,
hungry,
wrapping down a little maze,
right rapidly get a piece of cheese by the answer.
That rat,
if you have the hungry rata and you walk in some catheter as pets are terrified
as counts.
It reads like to even just say from different Medicap had just a different smell
than couch.
They know what cat smell like and don't like it.
So if you take your hungry rather throwing little caterpillars,
he'll sit down that runway like nat,
much faster than women's just hungry.
So running away from something that you're terrified element,
avoiding something that your property being terrified of and running towards
something you want is a good way of being knocked.
Somebody motivated.
And so at the second part of that program,
we have people,
they hold a very detailed plan about their,
and if the eagles prior code schools figuring out why would you like to be
better because he would take the first school,
how would your family's,
which to be better also with baby,
how would you be of more benefit to the community if you would take that book?
Cause it'd be nice if you could sort yourself out in ways that also sorted out
your family and then also sorted out in your community and since you're making
an implant,
but where the hell no name for all three,
it's more sustainable anyways.
Right?
So throw the famous psychologist show Piaget called celebrated state.
He says that it's like a game that everyone wants to play.
It's better if you're going to play a game to play a game that everyone wants to
play with it and that's a good,
that's a good indication that it's a good game.
And so if you could figure out how to fix yourself up in a way that we had
similar opinions to fix up your family and your community,
it's like,
hey,
everybody wins and maybe it would be good to play game the different liquids.
So we don't think of games that way.
Pretty awful,
but it's certainly possible getting joint that exist and so well courage and
that free speech.
One of the things that I do recommend that people who try these programs is that
they do the that because if that plan has been that the no plan at all and
you're going to come up with a better plan because what they haven't,
you know,
and so it's either a bad glad knows lab and no glamor is way worse instead of
that plan.
At least when you implemented that plan and you serve walking towards what the
plan is,
you'll see specifically where it is that you're an error like specifically.
And you'll learn from that and then you can use what you learn while you're
making the mistakes,
implementing your bad plan to make a better plan.
And if you keep doing that eventually,
like there'll be a lot of failure along the way.
That's the adventure of your life by the way.
If you do that and you keep laying on plan and learning painterly from your
failures and then directing the planet,
what'll happen is you get on target as you move through life and even though
you're hitting a moving target because life is complicated.
And so we have some,
cause we studied this site didn't make weight because we weren't convinced our
theories were necessarily accurate.
We found,
for example,
this was at Mohawk College Ontario.
Um,
people who get to the future authoring program before they went to college work.
The young men in particular,
especially the English young man sort of categorize the people who were pursuing
something that was career oriented or something sort of vaguely can find the
young men who had vacant triangles goals.
If they did the future authoring program,
they were 50% less likely to drop out of college in the first semester.
So it was quite staggering.
So,
so it's useful,
David,
something that's the moral of that story.
And so fact the courage,
um,
which is where I started.
So originally when psychologists were studying theory,
they assume that fear was something that you learn.
And you might think that because there you are sitting down,
they're pretty calm,
you know,
I'm afraid of anything.
And so you might believe that the normal state of the human being is calm.
And then we have to learn to be afraid.
You know,
psychologists could teach animals how to be afraid.
So one way you can teach an animal to be afraid.
This was done with rap,
just have your route and it's in his cage and it's like it's comradery and then
you turn off the light and then you like to Phi this floor a little bit,
right?
Cause you wouldn't have the route around for a while.
And so just enough to shock and that shock,
that causes pain.
That's a punishment like shocked to wrath.
You do that a few times,
like was on the rent freezes as the bag as hard,
that the light signifies shock and what the Rad is experiencing with the light
goes on his feeling or any title.
And so psychologists get that with tracks and they thought a hot has learned to
be afraid.
That's actually not true.
I'll talk about that while.
And so then they generalize that to human beings.
And so maybe you have a phobia mouse or something like that,
or maybe you're afraid of something.
The idea was while you learn to be afraid and we can teach you how to not be
afraid.
And so what the psychologist at the behavioralists was,
uh,
let's say,
let's say you were afraid of balloons.
Some people are afraid of balloons.
As it turns out,
it's kind of an absurd fear,
but that's okay.
You know,
they with metal and uplifting positive post to the face and they learned to be
afraid.
And so that was conditioning them to learn.
And so what you do is you sit the person down as,
uh,
you have the do and suicides.
And so they take deep breaths.
You pay attention to different parts of their body,
their feet and ankles,
their knees,
so forth,
all the way up the body and relaxing the muscles and put them in a state of
relaxation or breathing deeply.
And then you have to think about pillows or maybe you show them some balloons or
maybe you feel the whole cab room with cold.
It's flooding by the way,
just to be effective.
If you have to get someone over their fear of balloons,
like right now it's a little drastic.
But anyways,
the point is is that you introduce to the thing a trade tradeoffs.
Well,
they're relaxed and ideas.
That's counter conditioning.
The idea is that when you can't be relaxed and afraid at the same time,
and so if you can learn to relax in the face of the thing that you're afraid
that you won't be afraid of people,
but then someone knows.
So that's a pretty good in theory,
but it's wrong.
It's a good theory.
Just like the theory of the learn to be afraid actually theories exactly wrong
because you don't want it to be fragrance.
You bloody well know.
What you learn is how to keep the home.
And it turns out if that's even true for,
for wraps,
the psychologist's Jerry Mesh with the experiences,
experiments,
movement question is when you have that normal rap,
you guys think,
well here's the,
and he's in the cage,
he's kind of a home there.
So he's calm and you can teach them how to be afraid of the light.
So when you take the comradery,
it's the normal rap.
It's like then you teach them how to be afraid,
but it's kind of arbitrary when you decided that the rat is normal because if
you take a ride by the tail and say you drop in a new cage,
when he goes in that medication,
he is not a con man.
He's this sort of route.
You know,
you guys have brought you guys to chat.
Some of you help such as the scouts,
but anyways,
but some of you have probably move your cap to a new house and cats go like
that.
Like your Kevin Holmes and calm cow by cat standards,
which is [inaudible] is
one of the delightful things about the,
and you can scare them to [inaudible].
You know when a captured his hair stands on ams like that,
you know that's the same experience you have when you feel awe,
you know that your hair stands on end.
When you feel all,
it's the same response that an animal has to the Predator.
You know,
imagine you're like a mountain.
You'd see a title on that.
See your mouse and or 65 scale up the coyotes,
that cow was like 70 feet high.
You saw a 70 foot high titles.
You feel awe [inaudible] most of stuff and it doesn't make that's retired.
That's why they stand sideways to a dance backwards off doctors [inaudible]
it's frozen.
That's a normal graph as far as I'm concerned.
That's frozen wrap.
The thing that's absolutely terrified out of it's fine cause it doesn't know
what the hell it's doing or where it's going or what's going to eat it next.
That's normal.
That's the fear circuit on completely.
That's the standard condition of existence as far as I'm concerned because
existence is character on spike terror and death and the idea that the normal
condition is calm.
That's insane.
That's not true at all.
And so he put a rat in a cage and it's frozen that cause it thinks God only
knows what's here.
And then what it does is it's frozen and snips of it and if nothing kills it,
then it seems a little bit more specific and see if there's anything in there
and Kinda cap that would really drive,
you know,
to drink [inaudible] and see if we can turn that [inaudible] learned almost
everything we know about how the brain works from doing such things.
One scaredy wrapped so
and nothing kills him.
He gets a little gray,
he starts to move around and then we can just explore as the whole damn cage
every nook and cranny.
And then if there's nothing there that were killer app,
then upon now and then you think,
well that's the normal rap.
It's like,
well no.
What is terrified about,
what's the normal loud?
The Conrad is the Rathmines that's explored everything.
It's really useful thing to know.
It's unbelievably useful thing to know.
Now.
Rats don't generally live by themselves in cages.
We live in a hierarchy of other undergrads in a social world.
And so there's sort of like people,
and so
the reason that you're not terrified out of your skull right now,
even though you could weave is then you're in a higher repeat with to people who
basically share your culture is the sheriff.
Go for sure in your hands and you can predict it.
You don't know what these primates litmus from within.
There's probably 2000 people in here.
There's lease,
30 of you are seriously the range [inaudible] but everybody's behaving properly
and everybody's pointed in the same directions.
One was turned around completely understood.
See
what the hell is this Friday not to?
And we have an agreement here.
The agreement is everybody sits in their chair and everybody thinks this is the
front and no one makes too much noise.
And you know,
wave your elbows around.
It's like there's a lots of rules and everybody,
and you were told that's a rule
and you don't talk a lot to your partner,
let's say.
Well the electrodes on and you don't talk to yourself and you're certainly going
to yourself and hinder your forehead,
right?
So there's lots of rules that are keeping your anxiety circuitry under control
in this circumstance and everybody around you is being polite enough to act out
the rules and so your fear stays off.
And what are the races?
This is something that was,
see if it's really important to me when I finally figured out that the comrade
wasn't the normal map,
the terrified grab what's been normal lab and then the terrified rab had to
learn how to be calm and the way that it learns how to be calm was two sports
territory and buddy,
but have been natural environment to organize a hierarchy in that territory so
that every graduate,
exactly,
whatever it is every other rep is doing at all times come to a nice wrap
agreement that's the hierarchy and explore the environment and then they keep
their terrorist circuits off.
And the reason that people don't like to have their belief systems disruptive,
it's because it turns the terrorist circuits back on and no one likes that.
Not even a bit.
It's absolutely before a flight.
And so that's hardly why people are so invested in their belief systems.
So back to how you treat someone if they're afraid.
So you flooded with balloons,
whether they're relaxed and then they're not afraid to moons anyone.
And that actually works.
If you do it five or six times,
then there'll be able to tolerate balloons or mice or needles at a crime.
If a needle phobia,
he had a needle phobia that was so severe and he would undergo the surgery.
There's no anesthetic.
Right,
right.
So that's something,
right?
I mean you've,
you've had a dentist drill in your tooth.
It's like trevaway there,
but no needles.
I treated him behaviorally for it's needful.
Yes.
So what I did was,
first of all,
he trusted me and I have rules in my therapy session.
Like I am not going to do anything that we do not agree on period.
Ever.
Okay?
So that's the crucial issue.
If you're going to treat help,
something with the fear.
So I said,
well,
you probably need to get over this beautiful,
you know,
because I thought the whole dental surgery keeping it seems a little much,
and he needed to get blood tests and other things because you need to get a
needle down with him.
And so I said,
well,
let's see if we can get rid of this needle phobia.
He said,
okay,
we'll give it a try.
And I said,
okay,
well the first thing I'm going to do next session is I'm going to bring in a
hacker here with Neil.
I'm just going to put it on the shelf.
And I showed him exactly where on Michelle funds going to put it.
I said,
just look at that place in the shelf.
And I said that because if you're afraid to something,
you don't like,
come it.
So you avoided.
So one way of not being afraid of something is to not avoid it.
I said,
well,
just look on the shelf and get to know you with that.
So he said,
okay.
I said,
well,
okay,
next,
next time he came in I said,
well,
I have a seat.
Make yourself comfortable.
And see that spot.
I don't know last time if you look there,
you'll see a needle and Scott Sheath on it.
It's got a little orange capsule on it.
And so,
um,
I want you to just look at the needle.
Just look,
it said,
okay.
I said,
well,
how's that one said?
I'm kind of nervous.
And I said,
well,
just look at it til you're bored.
Boredom is a form of learning.
If you're afraid of something,
what you want to do is become bored by it.
And so,
and if you look at me long enough,
you'll get bored by it because it doesn't do anything and just sits there.
And he bought,
he said,
okay,
I'm,
I'm hot.
I said,
okay,
look,
I'm going to pick up the needle.
I'm not gonna bring them towards you.
I'm just going to pick it up.
I know it was lifted four inches off of the shelf cause I wanted him to know
what the hell was going on.
Sorry.
Left ended up in.
That made me kind of nervous.
I said,
okay,
I understand all of this new and renewed the same thing.
We just watch it until you're okay.
He said,
okay.
And I said,
lemon.
We did the next day.
I said,
well,
I've been a movement.
And I said,
well,
I'm gonna move it closer to you and you know any increments and you can stop me
whenever you want,
but I'll just move it an inch at a time.
And how will that be?
He said,
well,
I think that anyways,
by the end of the session,
I'd had the needle with the,
she's touching his arm and he leave me,
man,
he would have none of the room screaming if that would've happened,
you know,
the session before that,
and that was enough.
I didn't want to push it too far,
but here is with nothing.
I didn't have rocks.
Now it turned out when the behaviors,
if your experiments,
they found out that you definitely have to ask the person to relax in order for
the balloons to,
for voluntary exposure to the balloons to have me a sec.
Oh yeah.
News have been voluntarily expose themselves to what they were afraid.
It's like,
man,
that was a major discovery.
And if turns out that pretty much every school of clinical psychology has come
from agree on that.
How do you help someone with what you're afraid of?
And this is important because we're afraid of life,
right?
So if you figure out how you help someone over from their fear,
but that's a big deal because you're afraid of life and you should be because
life will kill you.
And so it's no wonder you're afraid of it.
And so what are you going to do about that?
It's not like people have phobias and so far,
no,
aren't afraid to face with no harmful.
They're often afraid of things that are harmful.
And the mystery is often why other people aren't afraid,
not why they are.
So
how do you help someone become less afraid?
You actually don't.
You actually help them become more courageous.
That's cause that's not the same thing.
It's like,
because like actually is dangerous and if your ability to prevail in life is
dependent on you not being afraid of life,
it's like that's kind of a nonstarter because there's lots of things that might
come to be afraid of.
And so if you to be successful,
it had to be not afraid of life.
It's like,
well,
forget about that because you know,
if you're on someone's deathbed and there's going to be some emotion associated
with that,
we're actually afraid of cats and we're afraid if it send the need,
we're afraid of the trailing,
we're afraid of pain.
No bloody wonder,
that's for sure.
And so it's not being afraid of it's necessary one,
then we're lost.
But that isn't what's necessary.
What's necessary is to be courageous.
And that's very,
very cool because it turns out that you could be more courageous than you think.
And also turns out that if you put yourself in a situation where you face the
things you're afraid of,
you find out that there's way more to you than you thought.
And what's also cool about that is it doesn't seem to be on the upper limit to
that because it isn't obvious to,
if there's anything that you can face without learning how to face.
And I mean anything.
When do you think about it?
Right?
People work in emergency wards,
right?
So think about that.
Well,
what they do is have emergencies all the time and you think,
well the emergency is something you can tolerate almost by definition would be
an emergency otherwise.
But people specialize in half.
So obviously they get used to it.
People work in Palliative care boards,
that's rough.
Everybody there is suffering and it's going to die soon and then they do die.
So not only are you dealing with that and dealing with loss estimates,
bossing people work in funeral partners,
so they're dealing with death all the time.
It's like people are bloody tough.
So my client,
he was pretty happy about that.
And so the next session,
um,
I told him I was going to take the sheets off the needle,
you know,
he was all right with that.
And then I waved to the,
but not do maniacally.
And then I did the same thing and I drove to the point where I can hold the
needle half an inch away from his arm without him being with him,
watching,
don't get flinching without turning away with him watching.
Cause that's the thing is he actually have to face the thing you're afraid of.
And so that was no for that session.
Then the next session,
part of it was trusting because he'd had a bad experience with dentists when he
was a kid.
And that was partly what produced his soybean.
So he didn't really trust people in authority deeply like a scared animal.
And that's what he said.
It felt like,
what's a scared animal?
That's the three d book.
Right.
And so the other thing I had in practice was telling me to stop and,
and leaving.
I said,
look,
we're going to,
you tell me to stop what I'm doing and then leave and I've won't stopped and
know.
I can just tell him that.
And he would have believed me.
But that's not the same thing as actually practicing and it happen.
So He'd say the needle,
you know,
and,
and around you can say stop doing that.
Stop.
And he'd say,
I'm leaving.
And then he'd get up and leave it.
I just let them leave until we get that five or six times.
Like he would do a per 10 playing thing with the kid,
you know?
And so then that God,
the idea of deep in him that if he could just get the hell out of here,
there are no,
it would bug him if he wanted to.
Part of increasing the trust that he had with me and so are the end of that
session,
I was able to cover the needle with a piece of paper so he couldn't see it and
touch his skin with a short bed.
So that was pretty damn good because that was both the needle like a needle.
Then you can see it as one thing and the naval.
Then you can see it's held by someone who'd been,
trust is another thing,
but a late,
you can't see that's being moved by someone that you sort of trust.
That's a whole different thing.
And he could manage that.
And anyway,
no,
if you have the doctor and his needles and so arranged for him.
And the moral of that story is you don't have to relax number features,
the things that you're afraid of.
You just have enough money,
want face.
And that's so cool.
Okay,
now let me tell you a different story.
So that's part of group
[inaudible].
One is you know of is set up straight with your shoulders back and people have
criticized that chapter misread or non branded [inaudible] what I'm talking
about,
I'm talking about hierarchies is pile,
you know,
then to standing up straight with your shoulders back and to somehow new
dominant and powerful.
And that's complete rubbish.
That isn't what that chapter is about at all.
It's about something else.
It's about the idea of it all.
If you're going to be successful in your hierarchy,
suppose things from Harvard for free range,
the best thing that you can be as courageous and because people admire George
and they promoted the name and the admired by late and they,
and they,
uh,
they mimicking and,
and if you're a courageous person,
then people are happy with you.
And then you can lead them and so forth.
And,
and to stand up straight with your shoulders back this to maximally expose
yourself to the world and such an extensive courage.
And so that's,
that's why,
that's,
that's why that's a useful thing.
And it turns out that our hierarchies told so much reward power for example,
as the reward offer id,
things,
competence and so forth.
But you develop confidence as the consequences of courage because you
development prominence by facing things that you don't have it yet mastered.
Overcoming your fear and learning to master them and then you become competent
and that moves you up.
The hierarchy in our functional hierarchies are predicated upon confidence and
competence is predicated on courage.
And so we should facilitate good way.
It's pretty good way of being in the world.
What does it do for you?
Why do you think there's no amount of you?
And there's a lot of the world and the world's a pretty dangerous place.
And maybe what you should do is go high,
but that doesn't really help to hide,
which is why it's going to parents.
And all they do is encourage you to hide.
Then you have bad parents and they just make you weak and then you're weak and
maybe you're hiding,
but it doesn't matter because no matter where you hide me,
you're never going to be able to hide from what you're afraid of.
Because wherever you are,
no matter how much do you hide the thing that you're afraid of,
we'll find you.
And even if it doesn't sign you in the world and in the near future,
we'll find you nightmares.
It doesn't matter.
There's no hiding from it at all.
And so as a parent who don't try to protect your children,
who tried to get some strong,
and you do that by exposing them to the world,
that's why you don't bother Jim Escape one,
not school rules or Memphis correctly.
11 this rule,
11 because skateboarding is dangerous doing it involves mastery and you want to
do your job,
the masculine World Cup to be protected from the world because there's no
protection from the world.
And if you tried to protect your child from the world,
then you are the thing they should be protected from.
So encouragement now,
watch what happens with you.
Load test yourself against it.
Well the first thing is learned something.
And so the psychologist Pha that I told you about before,
he watched how children learned that he looked,
he noticed it,
you know,
shop and try new things and experiment with new things.
And you know,
when my daughter was young for example,
sorry,
due to things that I felt quite cool,
she had this little box,
a cardboard box and was full of books,
cardboard books.
It was solid.
We bought this fake Disney books and about four that would fit into the little
bump box.
And they sit very tightly and when she would shake them out to the box and then
put them in,
it was hard in what she was doing was learning how to use your hands,
which is actually quite useful.
You may notice you use your hands and went to bed.
And so learning how foods to have is a good thing.
And so she would sit there and literally for an hour [inaudible] the books and
then putting them in and she could get it for me out before I had no problem.
But that fourth one,
man,
that was a pain and she just worry at 40 worried [inaudible] would go in and
that the first thing she did was shake it out of him achieving really
concentrating on that.
So she was,
she was mastering that technique that was fuck hand eye coordination,
which is very useful.
Let's see,
you want to stumble into things and be awkward.
So that's what she was tipped trying.
And then I watched her on the monkey bars in our backyard,
which she was very little.
She was only maybe two months old.
These monkey bars were too high for her and,
but she wanted to try them anyways and we would watch her with some
apprehension,
but we didn't run out.
Then we had to wait until she was three rounds out up and then and go,
oh my God,
but your fault so that she would fall and large endeavor to do that again.
Just what you do is you're a bad parents.
Yeah.
And then they say,
see,
I told you right.
That's fine.
You can check into those things you think you can do fall.
Just like I said,
as she's my scary,
sorry,
she'd be on the first wrong and it should do this
each.
Each time she left up her foot,
she left like an inch higher,
right?
She was just right on that edge of disaster,
which is the best place to play.
Everyone knows that play on the edge of disaster cause that's where you learn.
That's where it's exciting.
And the reason it's exciting is because that's when you're learning and your
brain is wired to make you excited when you're learning.
And so she was on the ragged edge being calm about it because she'd get her foot
up and get to the next rung and then,
then she did the same thing with the next one.
There.
You do it carefully.
So African American and she managed to go across the top of the monkey bars.
That was a good paid for her and a good day for us and hopefully that'd paper.
Okay,
well courageous and more confident that she would be.
So she learned something from doing that.
You know when you can say,
well,
she absorbed information from the world and build from cell phone with them that
that's the way of thinking about it.
You know,
the more things you do,
the more you go around the world and you do things and bang yourself up against
other people in other situations.
You learn what you shouldn't do and you learn what you should.
You know?
When you make yourself sharper and more in swarm in the formation,
that's what information means.
You put yourself in the formation with the world by incorporating the
information of the world and you do that by exposing yourself to things that you
haven't yet mastered and you would spend your mastery and that's deeply
meaningful.
It's that instinct of meeting is exactly that instinct that tells you when you
were optimizing the rate at which your competence is developing.
And that's a really lovely thing to know because you don't,
you'll find sometimes if you're engaged in what you're doing,
that's that that's a meaningful thing that you're doing.
And you mind saying,
well there isn't any meaning in life.
Actually the rents,
you just have to look around and see when it manifests itself.
And when it manifests itself is when you're expanding that zone of competence
does,
that's what meaning is there a signifier?
And so it's actually very reliable instinct and it's really real.
It is telling you that you're in the right place at the right time doing the
right thing.
So that's,
that's a great thing to know.
So,
so you inform yourself.
And so here's how,
here's a cool thing.
So in the shark does Egil Cathedral is a cross and a cross is a symbol,
a symbol,
an x,
and you're at the point of the episode that's the x marks the spot and the
support is you.
And if it's a cross,
at least the Christian world,
it's also a place of suffering.
And that makes sense because the x marks the spot.
It's you.
It's characterized by suffering.
So that's idea there.
And then the question is,
well,
what should you do about that suffering?
Because
well,
it started with that.
There's no avoiding it.
It's worse than that.
It's normally that there's no avoiding it and then it exists.
It's then a few don't know how to deal with it.
And it just grinds you up,
which it certainly will if you know how to deal with it,
then that would make you bitter and resentful and that will make you cruel.
And once your banner and resentful and cruel or they will start to become
destructive and then you'll suffer even more and know,
spread that everywhere.
So you actually need to know how to deal with fits.
And so in the sharp cathedral,
there's this very cool thing,
which is a big of room.
If it's a base,
it's a circle.
It's divided into four parts and it's a simple pilgrimage.
Okay,
so what happens if you're a medieval type?
When we go on a pilgrimage,
it's sort of what you do when you go to Europe,
you know,
or whatever.
Southeast Asia is real common for kids to go to now to,
it's sort of,
they grow up and they leave their parents and they go out on this pilgrimage and
they go where they haven't been and what happens when they go where they haven't
been as hypothetically,
they grow up,
they have some adventures that you,
some stupid things,
you know,
but they have some adventures and they take care of themselves and so when they
come back they're there more than they are because they went somewhere and they
have to be.
So there is a thing you want to be more than you are,
then you should go somewhere you haven't been.
And that's the idea of going on a pilgrimage to go to the center of the world.
You have a big adventure on the way there and then all the way back and then
you're not the same when you come back here more than you were.
Everyone should go on a pilgrimage once in your life.
Always had dealt with it,
just structured properly.
Then you go to the center of things and that's the idea of a holy pilgrimage.
Let's say that's something that people would have felt,
but not everybody can afford to go on a pilgrimage.
And maybe you can do it small.
We said that the sharp cathedral,
which is a cross,
there's a base,
it's a big piece of 40 feet across and it's a circle divided into four parts.
So it's the world north,
west,
east and sell.
And you can get to the center of the labyrinth,
but the way into the center as you entered the labyrinth,
and then you have to walk in these pathways that demarcate all of the quadrants.
And to get to the symphony,
you have to go everywhere.
That's an idea.
To get to the center,
you have to go everywhere.
And that's exactly right.
And so,
and why?
Well,
if you go everywhere,
and that takes courage,
obviously to go everywhere because you'd have to get in front of what you were
afraid to go everywhere.
Then you get to the centuries things.
But why?
Well,
here's one reason you,
you got a lot of information.
When you go places that's pretty straight forward.
You know,
and I'm sure if you think about it,
maybe I'm wrong about this,
but I don't think so.
What I've noticed in my life is that every time I tried to do something that I
actually tried to do that works,
it doesn't necessarily get me where was planning to go
with that plan.
I've never read and picking up a skill,
you know,
I pick up a stihl for a reason and that means it doesn't work out.
Then I've got the skill and then inevitably that skill comes in useful for
something along the way.
And so my sense is
the things that I've actually attempted to do,
you know,
put some spirited,
have paid off even though they didn't necessarily pay off the way that I
expected anyway.
That's okay.
That doesn't matter so much whether or not they paid off that matters.
So the more things you bang yourself up against voluntarily,
the more courageous you become,
the more skilled you become,
the more you're able to deal with your own suffering.
And that means the less drug you're going to be because suffering than you can't
manage mixing her up and suffering that you can bear and even bear notably in
honor of leading well,
then well,
that's the definition of a well lived life.
Here's something else that's cool.
So there's this idea that if you,
if you can confront the abyss and then in the abyss there's a monster in the
belly of the monster is your father and your father was laying there asleep or
dead.
You see that in the story,
but they'll queue.
It's a very,
very old idea.
very,
It's Elise 5,000 years old in,
in recorded form,
which means it's way older than that,
but it's really old idea.
You look at a few,
we should be.
So that's what terrifies you in the abyss.
There's a terrible monster than the most advanced of your father that he's half
again or to sleep and you see that.
No,
no,
you don't use a puppet marionette,
someone else's pulling his strings.
If you remember in the parochial movie,
you may remember this with Velcro goes to the rest of it is farther from the
depths.
Not only is he a marionette puppet,
he's also a jackass.
That's a bad combination.
And so not only as something else pulling his strengths,
he still wouldn't headed puppet,
but you braise nonsense because he's,
he's,
he's pathologized his capacity for,
for for truthful speech.
So he's really in rough shape,
but he goes down to the depths right to the bottom to see if the thing that
everything is most afraid of,
that's the whale on sterling.
We're may not foot.
He finds inside the way.
I won't even know.
There's no explanation in this story at all about how Japan got there is his
father and then he rescues his father from the belly of the whale and they go
back up to the surface.
Pinocchio becomes a real boy.
So that's very interesting and it's really interesting cause you go see that
movie,
right?
All of you pretty much have seen that movie.
It's like what the hell are you doing?
Going to see that moving.
You're watching drawings of a puppet led by a cricket,
go to the ocean,
find a whale to rescue his father,
and somehow that makes it real and you're all capable.
Makes perfect sense.
It's like we're making any sense at all
unless you're were engaged by,
is it because it's actually
true?
Here's how it's true.
This is something geneticists have discovered recently.
So first of all,
here's the thing is that if you face what you're afraid of your pants,
you're going to find all sorts of information,
right?
You're going to get it all sorts of information.
You get back that information in Gq and that's going to make you informed.
So that's part of,
as part of becoming you are
now some of that information.
You're going to get it from other people and those people cause you were
interacting with all of the time.
They're telling you all the time about how to behave and how not to behave,
how to be an honorable person and how not to be an awful person in.
The more you reflect that,
the more you take on the characteristics that are demanded of youth in some
sense,
in the way that an ideal is demanded itself.
If you think about that as a journal ideal,
at least in part,
you should be the great father.
That's who you should be.
You should grow up.
That's what you should get when everyone's telling you that at the top,
including you.
And so the more you hit yourself against the world,
the more of that information you're going to incorporate it into more of that
and you want to do come.
And that's something like rescue your father from the abyss.
But here's this thing that's even cooler,
and it's associated with this idea of the labyrinth as well.
So the labyrinth,
which is the pilgrimage,
you have to go everywhere to get to the middle.
So here's what happens.
If I take you out of your comfortable environment,
when to put new,
something new,
put you somewhere new or even better,
you put yourself somewhere new.
And that's the only thing that really works by the way.
So if I present you with a challenge and it's involuntary,
you'll produce a load of stress hormones and it'll paralyze him.
But if you take on the same challenge voluntarily,
you have an entirely different psychophysiological response to.
It's a completely different things.
You do it voluntary.
And so you have to confront the abyssal derelict.
What happens?
You put yourself in a radically new situation,
your genes turn oh new proteins and manufactured different structures in your
brain.
You turned your cell phone.
But we don't know the limit to that.
And so you haven't paid attention.
You know,
we're going to potentially as part what you could learn as a consequence of
being informed.
But there's also a potential genuinely there's a potential inside of you at the
molecular level and the way you turn that potential audience by struck,
by stressing yourself,
by challenging yourself,
right?
By adopting a sense of courage in the world and by pushing yourself beyond where
you are into new domains.
And the consequence of the VAT is,
is that the genes in your neural structures cold for Neupro proteins and they
may do a new thing out with you.
And we have no idea what the limit of that is.
It's so you think,
well,
what's that new thing that's being turned on?
Well,
obviously you know it'd be around for three and a half billion years.
You're not stupid.
Even though they asked student from time to time,
you have this limitless biological,
in some sense it's ready to manifest itself,
but it's not going to manifest itself.
That will key in.
It needs a reason to turn it on and so you go somewhere new voluntarily and
things that would help you cope with that new thing.
Turn on and then you might think,
well,
what would happen?
You can just go to the old it on and that's who that might be.
Well then you would need to be,
you should be and that would be equivalent to rescue your father from the belly,
from the base thing.
That would be that.
The same thing is take you on habit,
that architectural,
what would you call it?
That architecture than desirable structure of authority and incorporating that
in something like that.
Well,
what you need in order to do that is courage and faith to faith fit.
If you manifest courage,
that the consequences of that will be positive.
And the only way you look for find out is if you try it.
And if no one else can tell you,
pick an hint at it,
but you can't do,
this is something they can essentially.
So the 1953 is,
it's on you.
The only person that can find out if this is actually true,
it's you.
It's your the what she has to face the things that you're particularly afraid of
and you're the one,
there's an old story,
King Arthur and the knights of the round table,
they're often look for the holy grail,
which is the container of what everyone needs,
whatever that is.
And of course they don't know where an intelligible though for the holy grail,
who knows,
where do you go look for the holy grail?
And so they move away from the round table and they all enter the forest and
each of the master's before I step a place that looks darkness to him.
And that's when you started the search for the holy grail.
So that's very much worth knowing as well.
So courage for why do you need courage?
Because like this terrible suffering and it's malevolence and so you have every
reason to be terrified.
There was no real way out for them because that's the ground of existence,
but it turns out,
but that's okay because there's more genes than we think and the way you find
out if it's more and what that more is is by facing a thing that's terrifying
and maybe facing up thing.
That's my level and as well because that could be obligation to face the
suffering of the world and strengthened malevolence within it and it turns out
that even though that's an overwhelming task by definition that you're probably
up to it and if you took on the responsibility of doing that,
pulling terribly,
then what would happen is that you would discover that you were up to and what
the consequences of that would be,
at least in part is not so much that the suffering in life would disappear or
God only knows how much we can constrain it.
If we all seriously tried,
but then in the attempt to thinks any extreme,
you'll find a meeting.
It's so engaging and so overwhelming that that in itself will serve as a
medication against the suffering of him and malevolence that exists.
And all of that
appears to be just simply true.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
do a Q and a with the questions and hopefully you guys do over the Internet.
We've got a few things I can go over it very quickly.
First of all,
the shows us 48 or 49,
I believe when this tour every night,
a very different lecture.
So we are in London tomorrow night,
Ontario.
Uh,
you want me to join us in?
Both were in London,
England,
and the October we're in Kitchener,
then the following night,
there are still tickets available.
Let me come see us there.
Uh,
this door will continue to the u s and some timber,
uh,
the UK in October and hopefully,
abroad in 2019.
And the thing is voting for your translation with multiple languages and it has
really a phenomenon.
So you also mentioned,
I believe this,
some offering a program offering dotcom.
If you go there and the code to the 12 rules,
you can get up to 50% off,
5% off on the self authoring program.
Highly recommend that.
Okay.
And now with no further ado,
please don't think that will come back to the stage.
Dr. Jordan [inaudible].
So someone named Zachary Henderson said in Europe,
who is the handsomest man in the front row tonight?
[inaudible]
anonymous sense.
Um,
do you believe in aliens?
No,
but they exist whether I believe the number of [inaudible].
So someone said,
how do you reconcile the very strong interest in your work with what is
otherwise in general,
generally have an aesthetic and a disengaged approach to life.
So someone that's an island stuff first,
right?
Because
you know,
there's kind of two broad categories of existential catastrophe and one would be
the escape into totalitarianism that sort of crushes with its strictures.
And the other is to let everything fall apart and to become a nihilistic.
And the nihilistic attitude is generating,
predicated on the presumption now in life is fundamentally meaningless.
There's no superordinate meaning and because life is short and painful and so
forth.
And I think the answer to that is,
well,
the process of discovering because you can discover the point.
Um,
but you have to first of all,
assuming that you're too ignorant to begin with,
to know what it is and also to question your doubt itself.
No,
because if you believe that place is pointless,
then you believe that what you believe is correct.
And that means you believe your beliefs.
And it seems to me that you probably not smart enough to unquestioning belief
your beliefs.
And you might start with a question,
can your doubt,
why do we go with that?
Life has meaning.
Well,
you might say,
well,
it's just self evident given its suffering infinity.
It's like,
well no,
that's not so self evident.
Maybe you're just useless near responsible.
And you're justifying that by making the cakes that life has made less
something.
You don't have to do anything and you don't have to bear any responsibility.
That's actually quite helpful if you discover that because you think that
everything is pointless and horrible and it's just that you're useless and
that's way better because if you're just used to us,
you could forget and fix that.
But if life was pointless and horrible,
then you basically do.
So you can substitute nihilism for humility.
You can substitute humility for nihilism.
That would be a good start.
And then the first to ask this question obviously has a genuinely empathetic and
disadvantaged approach to life,
but finds that they're very strongly interested in my work.
Okay?
So then the first thing can do that is to notice that you're not
completely empathetic in this occasion.
You're apathetic condition,
but there's some spark in the darkness and you don't know why.
I could stare at east and this is a useful thing if you're feeling hopeless.
And I mean,
there's lots of reasons why someone might be feeling hopeless and sometimes when
people are feeling hopeless because they're physically ill in one matter.
So I'm not thinking about this as a universal panacea.
I know there's lots of reasons for being depressed.
Um,
and that,
that's not that easy to distinguish from being nihilistic.
But if you notice that there are some things that grip you,
that's a useful place to start.
It's like,
Oh look,
I'm interested in something.
Well that's a mystery,
right?
Cause you can't make yourself interested in something.
You can notice that they were interested in something and then you can pursue
it.
Interest to sort of like,
it's like a beacon.
The clippers in the darkness.
If you follow what you're interested in,
especially if you do an honest action.
A crucial,
which is why I wrote rule eight,
tell the truth or at least a lie.
If you're going to follow when you're interested in,
then you've been an [inaudible].
Because if you lie,
you have fun with John is the mechanism of interest.
And then it lead you off of cliffs.
So if you're gonna follow what you're interested in,
that you've been in the audience because otherwise you're following someone
dishonest.
That's a very bad idea.
So,
but in any case,
if you don't notice that you're interested in something,
even if you're interested in something like music,
I don't care what it is,
if you're interested in something,
then that thing that you're interested in in guidance,
you know what we need in the Harry Potter movies there,
they played that quidditch game.
And you know that's a funny game because there's the normal game,
sort of like basketball.
So if you played on brooms and then there's a game that rises out of that,
which is the gate of the secrets play,
there's two secrets.
And they chased this little ball with wings on it.
That's actually an ancient symbol as the hell chemical chaos.
And it's uh,
it's the container of the unrevealed world.
That's what the hell,
chemical chaos.
Cause that's what that stitches interesting way.
How Fun.
I don't know how they helped JK Rowling ever figured that out,
I think is,
it's unbelievably obscure knowns.
But she gets figured out and the secrets chased that and that thing flipped
around,
right?
And it goes ever.
It's like a mercury,
the winged messenger of the gods.
It's the same idea.
And the secrets follow this thing that fits around,
that's a Goldman glitters and bleed and that's meaning itself.
And the idea that's expressed in the game of quidditch is that the person who
pursues meaning and fights and is when something of such colossal magnitude that
the entire game is that everyone who was blame,
something of such a colossal magnitude that he is declared victorious right at
that moment.
That's really what that is symbolizing in the structure of the movie,
which is so cool.
But you manage that and it's such as such as stroke of genius,
but you can do that in your life.
You know,
there'll be things that glimmer in glitter for you in the darkness.
And you said,
Andrew is a person.
How's this question,
um,
that you hit and you have a strong interest in my work?
Well then I would say be a little more precise.
Right?
Exactly.
What is it that you're interested in or decisive?
What is it that's gathering your attention?
Because that's up marker to the,
that's a door.
That's the doorway through which you must pass into your life.
That's what that is.
And that's what meaning marks out for me.
No,
it's likely we see,
we see in front of us a set of doors,
so that's the,
that's the world in front of us is an infinite set of doorways and,
and we can open the doorways and all sorts of things will come out.
We don't face some that were not determined by the material reality around us,
but we are to some degree that isn't the world that confronts us.
The world that confronts us is a vast expansive potential and possibility.
You all know that I can wake up in the morning and you think,
well there are things to do or there are ways that I can behave that will
produce certain consequences,
some negative.
It's a positive.
It's this expansive potential and that was certainly what you in front of them
as a human being is you confront the expensive potential with your consciousness
and your consciousness is exactly that which transformed that potential into
actuality and your moral and your moral and your morality determines whether you
transformed that potential into a good world or a bad word.
And you all know that too,
because you know that you can make bad decisions and make things worse and you
could make their decisions and make things better.
And so that's an actual too,
that's an echo of what happens in genesis when God creates the world of chaos is
it's a decision to,
to speak the truth and to interact with the Kaylyn jumps on to produce having
[inaudible].
It's in that image that were made.
That's the story.
It's a great story.
And we all believe it cause we treat each other like that and predicated or into
our political system.
And the idea that that's what we are.
And then you might say,
well how will it was due doorways in front of you and which one should you open?
That's her as well.
How about the people?
But the one that clips and it attracts your attention.
And that's a deep manifestation of the instincts,
the meeting.
And so something beckons t and then you can open it and then something comes out
of it.
And that changes everything.
And then what beckons will change.
And that's what happens when you follow your instinct.
For meeting,
but you have to be humbled to do that.
You have to be willing to see what it is that glitters of the darkness and you
have to lower yourself so that you're willing to pursue it because it won't be
something high and mighty to begin with because why the hell should it be if you
don't know what you're doing and you don't know who you are and you're enveloped
in chaos and you're at your,
what would you say?
Hopeless.
And I'm disciplined than useless.
Why would something magnificent manifest itself for you to begin when it's
supposed to be something small enough so someone like you would have to get on
their hands and knees to,
to approach.
Maybe you have to clean up your room.
Maybe you have to scrape the dust bunnies underneath your bed.
You know,
maybe you have to do those things that you know you should do that you've been
putting off because they're beneath you.
It's no,
they're now,
I haven't no money or exactly what you have for is go have no matter how small.
And so you would talk to your responsibility and you follow it.
Beckons is meaningful and you do that.
And humility knowing that you're not in a position to judge the world and you
say,
I haven't generally apathetic and distribution approach to life,
it's like well what makes you think you're a reliable structure meeting?
Why?
It's a good question.
So before you dismiss the cost monks as insignificant,
you might want to make sure that you put yourself together to the degree that
you can,
cause you may be missing something you never know.
So [inaudible]
does
everything you believe makes you hopeless.
Then maybe you would question the utility of what you believe.
And I ran in a cocktail hour,
cocktail hour,
a woman talks to a psychiatrist,
I believe that a party,
hence the cocktail hour.
And she's trying to ask him for professional advice and she says,
look,
I'm having a pretty rough time in my life is not what it should be.
If I'm suffering from Marilyn
and I really hope there's something wrong with me.
And the psychiatrist is sort of taken aback but there's something wrong with
you.
And she says,
well,
as far as I can tell him,
it's only two possibilities.
Either there's something wrong with me and that's why I'm suffering
unsupportive.
Or there's something wrong with the structure of existence and that's why I'm
suffering.
And if there's something wrong with the structure and existence,
well then what am I going to do?
Nothing.
But if there's something wrong with me,
then I can fix it.
And so that's chapter six,
which is the dark chapter in 12 months.
Your life is to meditation on the motivation of people who do such things as
shoot up elementary schools.
And the rule is put your house in perfect order before you criticize the world.
And if everything is around you was meaningless because of your beliefs.
The first thing you might think as well,
maybe it's your beliefs and not the world.
And so that's,
that's not believable.
Helpful thing to realize.
You've been dealt with your own
[inaudible]
on
your website.
I'm six foot piece of art,
so that's about six feet square.
It's made for cases like the labyrinth that I've described and it's later.
It's fun and it's a bit of a quarter inch layer of some full course,
full court to say it's a labor room start foam with a layer of paper on each
side and the software,
new institute
as backing for prints and so forth or frame Darren works.
But I decided about the 1980s with,
I'm just going to make foam core sculptures that were half sculpture and have
pagans.
I made half a dozen of them before I ended up doing other things.
And one of the things that I made back then was this sculpture that I called the
meaning of music.
And I was really interested in music at that point,
partly because I was trying to sort out the phenomenology of meaning.
What is meaning and is it something real?
If it's something real,
what does it represent or what is all of that?
And one of the things I had noticed was that people fall,
we music intrinsically meaningful.
And that was very interesting to me because even nihilistic people couldn't help
but find music meaningful.
And so it was 1983 or [inaudible] 84,
um,
punk rock movement was still pretty
powerful.
It's still a going concern that function like the sex pistols.
And
I noticed that even the nihilistic punk rock I just found there.
And nihilistic,
extremely meaningful,
which I thought was [inaudible] celebrating,
anarchic,
nihilism.
They were brilliant to their music.
[inaudible] using these two because it's an art form and it goes underneath
thinking.
It's also a good antidote to,
to rational skepticism,
which is why music has become such a powerful force in our culture.
People love music.
And I think without music,
any people just died.
And it's because music speaks of meaning directly.
Like when you listen to music,
when you're into it,
when you're enjoying it,
you're not really enjoying it.
You're finding the experience meaningful.
And,
and it's fun to watch people play music because they can train themselves,
watch people improvise,
you know,
because they're all trained together and doing this normal thing.
They're all got the average where they shouldn't be there doing it beautiful
again.
So I talked a lot about what music represented.
Um,
and I spent about four months making,
this is painting and I thought what are we trying to do is to make a piece of
art that represented visually what music represented in the auditory relevance.
So if you look at that local,
they'll see that it's like a neck Q,
but nick was really just one of those reversing cubes and I made the,
I made the painting so that you couldn't resolve at visually so that if you look
out,
if gaze at it without focusing too much on,
just see that it moves,
it moves,
moves,
moves as your brain tries to resolve what it is.
What it actually is is a cube set on an without with a tunnel about the mental,
it broken into four fragments.
Another thing that it is,
it's a,
it's a three dimensional representation of a two dimensional representation of a
foreign object.
That's actually because music is a four dimensional object,
right?
Because it has three dimensions,
spatial spatial dimensions because you don't use it as rained in space.
That's what happens when you listen to stereo if see,
feel or hear how it's a rating space.
And then it just unfolds across time.
So it's got four dimensions.
And the reason music is meaningful and Mr [inaudible] an awful long time to
figure out is because the things that you see in the world that you think are
objects aren't objects.
They're actually patents and their patterns that you interact with in a manner
that makes them into tools.
And so often the tool,
so you're a pattern because you maintain your structure across time.
So that's about having something that big canes instructor across time.
And so all the things that we perceive,
our patterns and patterns,
all the patterns,
there's a world and there were many,
I mean you think about all the patterns here and they don't have,
right?
You go down to the subatomic level and there's an array of pallets,
and then above that,
at the atomic level,
there's another array of accountants.
And then at the molecular level there's another array of patterns.
And then your organs are patterns.
And then there's youth,
it's a powder.
And then there's you moving through space with all these other people.
And that's a pattern.
And then there's the political system.
Or let's say that the town that we're in and down,
some pattern in the political system,
not some pattern and the ecological system,
and that's a pattern.
And then there's the cosmos itself and that was a pattern and that's the harmony
of the spheres.
All those patterns are interacting in a harmonious way and that's what music
represents.
It represents the harmonious interaction of the patterns of the world.
And then when you go out to a bar and your doubts and what you're doing is
you're a regular body alone without pattern,
you find that deeply meaningful like you should because you shouldn't read the
body in alignment with the patterns of the world.
And then when you dance with someone else and maybe that was someone that you
love,
then you mutually produce a pattern and you're improvising with each other to
produce that pattern and your simultaneous aligning the pattern that you're both
producing with all the pack.
We all any of the music.
And so you're acting out the action,
you're acting out the act of engaging in a dialogue,
dialogue,
just dialed belt,
right?
So you're engaging in a dialogue that produces a pad that adapts you to the
structure of the patterns of the world and that's what you're doing and you're
dancing.
And so I figured all that out with regards to music and turned to portray that
in that logo and that simple.
And then since then I've been experimenting with that symbol joined to see how
many different forms I could get it to tenants as I can get it to manifest in
the world.
And so it's propagating like mad.
And that was part of what I wanted to do when I made 35 years ago.
I thought,
I'll make this thing and see how many different ways it will manifest itself in
the world.
So that's the story of the local [inaudible].
Okay.
[inaudible]
by
you're not going to be,
you're on someone's deathbed
even.
So you have to be extraordinarily careful with their terminology.
When people say that they want to be happening,
first of all,
they don't mean that.
When you say you wouldn't be happy,
that's not actually what you mean.
There's plenty of psychological evidence that,
because if you take measures,
we all be,
and you analyze the statistics,
what you find is that when people really don't want is to be anxious and
impatient.
So happiness is a positive emotion over and above that.
But if you force people to make a trade on scale,
don't pick absence of misery and anxiety.
But that's,
that's the fundamental,
that's the fundamental motivation.
And so,
and then regards to happiness,
it's a,
okay.
Happiness is something that comes upon you if you're fortunate and it comes with
some more likely to come upon you with you're pursuing something that's
worthwhile and meaningful and awesome.
Awesome.
And the problem with assuming that the emotional state is actually the goal is
that when you're in situations where that emotional state can't possibly be the
goal,
and so that would be when you're dealing with the tragic reality in some fights
and your ethos is the pursuit of happiness.
That erm,
you know,
let's set you up a sick child for three years,
four here.
More say good luck with your happiness hypothesis because that's not going to
get you through it.
And I'm not saying that you should be cyclical.
Happiness was it.
You should despise him if it comes your way.
But it's just not the problem.
It's not a noble pursuit.
And it will,
it will lead you burettes situations of dire necessity.
You need something much more profound and yourself in the world.
And that's why I talked more about suffering it malevolence cause those things
are undeniable and the cause and then do a bunch of trouble.
And at minimum you can orient yourself in the world cause you take game against
both of those and attempt to get sprayed them.
That's something you can do even in the most dire of circumstances.
And so if you're dealing with someone who's in pain on it,
if you're dealing with someone who's dying or you're dealing with the
catastrophes of your life,
you still have a meaningful option of trying to reduce the suffering to the,
to the maximum possible,
the great.
And that's a worthwhile endeavor.
And so it's a much more adult way of orienting yourself in the world.
And if happiness happens to come your way,
well then good for you to win.
It's not wonderful.
That's something to be thankful for,
but it's a side effect and not a person.
Damian says doing what you do must be stressful.
Shoghi one wine.
Why shoe shopping?
Some people think I've already complete
[inaudible]
okay,
well it's,
it's stressful I suppose in some ways.
I mean,
um,
these,
I don't,
these talks particularly stressful because they're so positive.
You know,
I like to come up and talk about the things that I've learned and to seal from
New People here and have a serious discussion about things that would help
orient us in the world and to push what I know farther it happened.
So that's,
it's so positive that I don't really think about this.
Certainly this part of it as stressful facing journalists to stressful,
not always usually and often.
And so
I dunno how I'm the wine from that.
I usually go sleep afterwards I guess is what I do that help me.
That was helpful.
Um,
what I get for to
increase my ability to tolerate the activities that I'm engaged in.
This,
I travel with my wife and she's extremely helpful cause she's very level headed.
I have an extra brain along,
which is a useful thing.
And uh,
we swear sometimes with work workout with them,
sometimes we go for a drive where we can do that and we go for a walk and I
spend time with my family and um,
those are all good things.
Um,
but I go,
life is stressful.
So,
and at least I'm in a position where whatever I'm doing,
it's stressful is counterbalanced by exactly what that talks from all of you
tonight about it's deep what I'm doing,
what I'm engaged in is deeply meaningful.
And so it's a pleasure to be able to share that with other people and to see
that sense of meaningful engagement,
develop more people.
And
I can't think of anything better to do than that,
which is why I'm doing what I'm doing tonight.
For example,
I can't think of anything better than sitting here and talking to all of you
about these things that are necessary to understand and to lay out in the world.
And so
what do I do to unwind?
I think I do what you shouldn't do if you want to unwind.
I,
I'm trying my best to make things better
because it seems to me that would be better if they were better.
Simple.
And I have some sense of how bad things can be because I've studied how bad
things can be.
And I experienced some of it in my own personal life,
some of them with my clients because I've been in very dark places with my
clients and in my own life from time to time and certainly in my studies.
And I would grab him that everything.
Did you go to hell in a hand basket like it?
And I would like it if everyone got on the board and we all decided to make
things better.
Each of us started with our own lives and facilitating that is
that afternoon to the catastrophe of life.
And so that's a continual unwinding in a sense.
So,
and it's a privilege to be able to take part in m to also see this amazing
thing.
If I'd been developing for a long time now,
you know,
I started doing these lectures,
public lectures were getting last year I did a series on the Bible,
which I thought was really quite comical that,
that word because um,
well think about it is I decided to do a series of lectures.
So I rented the theater and I decided that I wanted to do lectures on,
on gems inspections of what responsibilities,
starting with genesis,
and then I would do that publicly and then a whole bunch of people came.
No.
So that was pretty weird.
A lot of them are young men for exactly not the people who would ever tell them
to do that.
So they have lots of people have about 2 million,
two and a half a million people have watched the first of those lectures.
It's on the first sentence of Genesis.
So to Mt.
Two and a half million people have watched the three hour lecture.
It's three hours long on one sentence
from the first story in the Bible.
It's completely ridiculous.
When my book launched,
the publicists in,
in London rented.
It's either so that I can talk about it sold out right away.
So then they rented number one for the next day and it's sold out right away.
And so they rented one the next week and it's sold out too.
And then the same thing happened in Amsterdam.
And then I thought,
well that's interesting.
So dope,
15 theaters,
15 theatrical performances in Toronto would then for Europe,
I can probably go whatever and in the world and can here and we'll talk about
what I want to talk about,
how much people will come.
So I thought,
well,
I wash and dry that that Caesar [inaudible],
my wife and I have been in,
I think this is the 58 city in four months and so,
and the here,
here you all are.
And we're having a very serious conversation ourselves properly in the world.
And so that's not stressful,
man.
That's great.
So it compared to there's so much worth catastrophe in the world to be involved
in a continual conversation with thousands of people about how each of our
individual lives might be better and how that could spread into our families,
into the broader community.
It's like that's not stressful.
That's the opposite of stressful.
It's great.
It's wonderful.
It's so far as that.
I can't believe it you,
I was talking to my son the other day,
this morning,
I think it was this morning [inaudible] paid with Tammy and I,
we have a hell of a trip from big order from Dublin to London Dublin.
I talked to Sam Harris and govern the summary and 8,500 people showed that port
and this big stadium.
It was like the biggest philosophical discussion.
I think it was the biggest public philosophical discussion.
Not Common.
It's not like [inaudible] was that will be the biggest event and was like all
these people showed up cavernous Rena to him to hear a very difficult discussion
about the relationship between facts and values and religion and science.
They were like right into,
you know,
we were going to switch to Q and a after an hour of discussion,
but the audience voted overwhelmingly with my clapping too to continue the
conversation.
So we talked for two and a half hours,
never cruise like right on the board.
And so it just turns out that people are lot smarter than we thought.
There's a huge,
huge,
well I think TV,
the narrow bandwidth of TV maybe made we were stupid and we're actually not.
And so there's this massive public hungered for detail and,
and,
and reasonably deep philosophical discussions like well that's a helpful thing.
So that was just beyond belief.
[inaudible]
we did that and I was crazy,
exciting,
ridiculously adventurous and the talk went really well and we'll take it
hopefully,
like I said,
that we'll be able to in August.
And then people can see when there was a discussion about the relative merits of
an atheist materialist viewpoint,
that's cultural or religious traditions,
religious viewpoint.
And we had a good discussion on both sides of that argument.
And then,
you know,
with any luck,
a couple of million people will watch those videos and they can have a
discussion about it and maybe the concern themselves up property.
And then we went to London and did the same thing again.
And along with a variety of,
of,
of other activities.
Like I said,
I was talking to my son about it this morning and he's a pretty tough kid and
pretty level headed.
And when he was talking about it,
it made him,
he broke down at the of crime.
And you know,
and the reason for that is because it's absolutely overwhelming to watch this
happen.
I can't believe.
So it's not stressful.
It's,
it's,
it's a privilege to be doing next.
It's an ounce of bloody privileged to be doing this and that.
So [inaudible]
how do you move forward advice after having made every granted huge mistake.
You know,
this is one of the reasons that I,
and I take the biblical elections I did last year were so helpful to me.
And I think that the people,
one of the things that's quite interesting about those stories,
Abrahamic stories in particular is it was bloody people.
They just make mistakes all the time.
So Abraham,
for example,
no,
he was chosen by God.
I pathetically like all the people
were,
I mean,
he just takes one absolutely catastrophic mistake after another.
And so that's life man making in regretting huge mistakes.
Now that doesn't mean that you should just go and propagating the mistakes,
so you have to take responsibility for it.
But the people that I've watched in my life lived property that say they learned
from their mistakes,
but they didn't beat themselves to death because of the,
you know,
when you think,
well,
so this is,
well this was a regretted it to Dell.
And it's like,
well we don't take adulthood is out in the public square and stone.
And so you probably shouldn't do that to yourself.
You know,
if you regret it,
well then what?
You have to do least you have to repent and you have to atone.
Okay.
And so what is [inaudible]?
Well,
it means you have to go over what you did and you have to figure out now that
you know it was a mistake,
you have to figure out why you were Sadam clueless since of damage,
stupid and exactly what we did wrong.
Like with each decision point,
like you know when you first met the person that you have the affair with,
you probably flirted with him a little bit more than that.
Then you,
you probably flirted with him to a degree that you regarded as Miskiw epic
access.
Did Eddie ones snow?
You have to figure out,
well why in the world did I think that was a good idea?
Then you have to know he'd sack.
So if you're a,
if you're walking down a path and you'd get lost in wonder us without that,
you get lost.
You have to figure out how it is that you wandered off the path.
Because the purpose of of Rick head take let's say,
so that when you're back on the path,
first of all,
you can find your way back.
That would be the first purpose.
The second is so you don't wonder off again.
And if you wondered off once that your pro,
the wandering off in that matter in so then you have to figure out why you who
wandering off in that manner right down into the most painful level of detail.
And then you have to figure out how not to do it again.
And as soon as you figure out how not to do it again,
then you should start beating yourself up.
You know,
because you've learned your lesson.
That's sort of the principle.
I try it out once the principles of discipline for children in chapter five what
is the district's goals?
Is you still more forced than this necessary minimum necessary for us,
it's a great,
and you said on your cell phone you make mistakes.
You know what?
Maybe so you have to finger second when you get wrong criteria.
When can you send him,
did something wrong.
You said you regretted it okay and get something wrong.
Whereas you with regret or less pick your just regretting the fact that part of
your life and you actually,
you know what nuts that's feeling,
sorry for yourself,
that's going to regret it.
It's going to happen to sort those things out because you don't get to feel
sorry for yourself.
You just to give to regret.
And if you read,
read,
read it into get something wrong and then you got to figure out what you did
wrong.
Exactly right down to the detailed levels and what was wrong with your
perception and your beliefs that led you in that direction.
Everyone would have to do to put that right and then you have right.
And then maybe you have to call rob,
make it manage all the people that you heard and then you have to be back.
And then perhaps you'll find yourself back on the path.
And then you have to stay on the path as best as you can.
And,
and that's Kate in some sense because if we all had to pay the ultimate price
for our sins,
if every single one of us would be
just as part why the concept of original sin still useful and everyone feels it
because everyone's guilty.
Never once ashamed.
So we have this inbuilt sense of something going wrong.
And if we can name it,
it just hot sense.
And that's why the idea of original sin isn't so useful.
Even though it has perhaps some conceptual problems associated with it.
Perhaps it's normal.
But
in this particular situation you don't,
you're a bad person.
But so is everyone else.
So it doesn't mark,
do you?
Well as particular horrible.
That doesn't mean the horrible.
This isn't real.
But it's not just you.
And then what you do about it.
This,
you're trying to be better.
And that's what we do about what's wrong with you to begin with.
Every,
every one of us,
we've all got things to learn,
man.
And plenty of them.
The world is what it couldn't be.
That's our fault.
And so we've got lots to learn it.
So to you,
and you try and learn it.
You treat yourself with firm enough that you learned and not harsh enough having
something you've died on your burn
[inaudible]
[inaudible].